on ice terre qui est avec nous esther de
narbonne salut esther merci d'être là
vous avez 23 ans
oui c'était à faire vous êtes vous êtes
en école d'infirmière alors j'étais en
école d'infirmière d'accord c'était
jusqu'en 2019 c'est ça c'est ça jusqu'en
juin 2009 exactement
j'ai eu un accident du coup mais si fait
que ça fait bientôt deux ans que je suis
de retour chez mes parents à narbonne et
que j'éprouve de grandes difficultés
pour alors vous vous allez nous raconter
ce qui ce qui s'est passé vous allez
nous raconter votre vie avant votre
accident et ce drame qui va bouleverser
votre vie en tout cas merci d'être avec
nous ce soir
avant votre vie avant avant l'accident
vous en étiez vous étiez en deuxième
année d'école d'infirmière tout se
passait bien
bah oui très bien je vais mama ma
meilleure vie parisienne avec mes potes
enfin c'était le top j'étais à
l'internât en plus bien que c'était
génial
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai fait
une chute ce personnel mais voilà j'ai
fait une chute ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui je suis pas rappeler
jusque là d'accord et depuis vous êtes
toujours en arrêt maladie aujourd'hui
c'est ça exactement
et j'aimerais reprendre une école
d'infirmières et non me refuse parce que
l'établissement n'est pas acceptée ou
alors c'est ce que on axe n'accepterait
pas en établissement pour faire mes
stages ça c'est ça c'est madame amis ça
c'est vrai que c'est la bonne personne
je rencontre pour les situations de
handicap et c'est vrai que c'est assez
c'est il ya beaucoup beaucoup de d'école
qui ne les accepte pas part ça on en a
parlé avec la ministre a par sophie
cluzel secrétaire d'état et c'est vrai
que ça c'est inadmissible parce que
esther en fait c'est pas possible que sa
vie puisse basculer non seulement parce
qu'elle
et choisit un handicap elle n'a pas
choisi mais elle voudrait continuer sa
formation d'infirmière elle veut être
infirmière et et elle veut vivre son m
et aujourd'hui elle peut pas le faire
d'abord fin c'est vraiment une épreuve
assez terrible hein que vous traversez
que vous avez traversé moi je pense
qu'effectivement on peut pas accepter
questerre puisse pas aller au bout de
son projet et vous avez cité sophie
cluzel je peux vous assurer qu'on on est
déterminé à ce qu'on puisse dans toutes
les filières continuer à se former les
écoles elles doivent être accessibles
c'est vrai que c'est plus le sujet
dessiner loin des messins absolument
voilà c'est 2005
vous avez raison de le dire et oui ça
date voilà la dette s'était pas hier
ouais effectivement non mais enfin moi
aussi si vous voulez poursuivre dans
cette boîte je comprends que c'est le
cas oui oui oui oui c'est ce que je vais
faire
on va vous aider à aller dans cette voie
a trouvé une école d'infirmières qui
peut vous accueillir
et puis surtout à voir comment on peut
organiser les stages et dans quels types
de services hospitaliers parce que c'est
c'est clair qu'il n'y a pas de raison
que vous puissiez pas exercer ce métier
est en fait le problème c'est pas
l'école c'est parce que l'école y en
existe une
une seule à castelnau-le-lez brême
accepter maintenant
l'école d'infirmières c'est une partie
théorique et une partie en stage donc il
faut que je trouve des établissements
qu'ils m'acceptent et moi ce qu'on m'a
répondu c'est on ne trouvera pas
d'hôpitaux publics privés qui vous
accepterez parce que vous êtes en
situation d'handicap est en fauteuil
voilà tu voulais ces mauvaises réponses
mauvaise réponse aux récents
il faut qu'enfin on va vous accompagner
pour trouver la bonne école alors et
s'assurer qu'on peut organiser des
stages
justement il est avec nous ce soir la
directrice de l' agence de communication
les papillons de jour katia die enquête
avec nos demandes de l'accueillir merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la 4c papillon de l'once est une agence
de communication est une entreprise
adaptée vous employez au minimum 80 % de
personnes handicapées dans votre
entreprise c'est sa moelle actuellement
mais est ce que ces pardons pas des
surprises adapté moi oui en fait
elisabeth borrel fruits et techniques un
seul a pu miser travaille au chili c'est
soit bon ou c'est d'aider les
entreprises à la ccl en fait les
entreprises adaptées ce sont des
entreprises qui embauchent 80 % de
personnes en situation de handicap
et puis ou alors sorti de l'emploi voilà
alors papillons de jour depuis 13 ans
est bien sûr c'est exactement ça
fonctionne et bravo à vous quatre heures
pour ce que vous faites et avec la copie
de plus de cinq cent mille personnes en
situation de handicap se retrouvent au
chômage
sachez le ccc un drame qu'est ce que
vous proposez alistair déjà un mentorat
oui les vêtements alors déjà c'est mon
métier depuis 13 ans donc déjà vous
recevoir je vais vous trouvez sans aucun
problème c'est un emploi et une solution
et c'est vraiment je m'engage parce que
c'est mon métier et c'est vraiment ce
que je fais tous les jours au quotidien
trouver des solutions depuis 13 ans pour
des personnes qui sont en situation il
ya des gens qui regardent sont dans le
même cas décider eux mêmes aux actes et
donc papillons les papillons de jour
voilà et vous pouvez contacter katia où
ses équipes parce que voilà ça vaut pour
pour ester mais ça vaut pour vous qui
nous qui nous regardaient vous je vous
ai dit ce soit peut-être qu'on va
trouver des solutions adaptées peut-être
que vous êtes dans le même cas questerre
et que vous connaissiez pas les
papillons de jour et ben voilà les
papillons de jour on va mettre un on va
vous mettre voilà comment comment les
comment l'art et ben voilà on va très
bien voilà donc vous contacter de katia
et ses équipes et katia demain si vous
êtes un amour je pense que externe c'est
bien bah oui mais voilà s'il ya des
domaines du médical qui est proposé oui
sans aucun problème et je sois vous
mettre dans la clim à vous aussi
vous voulez c'est c'est mon métier j'ai
sert de passerelle vers l'emploi en fait
entre les entreprises et les personnes
en situation de handicap ou pas en tout
cas qui sont à la recherche d'un emploi
et e mails problème c'est que moi du
coup j'ai pas de diplômes parce que
j'étais assez sympathique sa formation
j'ai pas tous les bagages
comment on va faire parce que ce qu'il
va commencer déjà par une formation
c'est sûr mais on va trouver la solution
parce qu'à partir du moment où on va
vous écoutez pas vous entendre trouver
la formation adéquate dans un lieu
accessible ce que c'est vrai que c'est
un véritable sujet aujourd'hui
l'accessibilité en france je pense que
c'est la municipale difficulté un
célèbre on a beau avoir des formations
adaptées si c'est pas accessible c'est
ça ma chance et je pense que c'est
important qu'on y travaille ensemble on
arrive finalement à vous trouver une
cible exacte
un ministre du travail il faut
travailler c'est ça